bienvenue sur lcp et public sénat c'est
l'heure de parlement hebdo 45 minutes
pour refaire l'aktu politique et
parlementaire avec michaël szames
évocateur pour michael cette semaine le
coup d'envoi de la discussion budgétaire
a été donnée à l'assemblée au menu la
suppression de la 1ère tranche de
l'impôt sur le revenu objectifs du
gouvernement faire 21 milliards
d'économies pour réduire le déficit pas
assez selon bruxelles qui menace la
france de sanctions libérez investir
travailler c'est la devise des manuels
macro le ministre de l'économie a
dévoilé les grandes lignes de son projet
de loi pour relancer la france de ces
blocages de ses corporatismes il faut
réformer les professions réglementées
les notaires les avocats les huissiers
et il propose d'assouplir le travail du
début étaient les allocations familiales
mise sous condition de ressources la
proposition l'ire du groupe socialiste
de l'assemblée soutenue par le
gouvernement elle suscite une vive
polémique la mesure sera discutée la
semaine prochaine au palais bourbon et
pour collecter toute cette actualité
notre invité eric woerth bonjour ancien
ministre du budget on va beaucoup parler
cette semaine notent aussi député ump de
l'oise maire de chantilly
vous connaissez le principe de cette
émission ce sont vos camarades vos
collègues qui vaudrait c'est un petit
peu votre portrait vous propose de les
écouter évidemment on commande juste
après c'est compliqué de parler
d'eric woerth c'est quelqu'un qui a
sûrement souffert
qui a été victime d' attaque et je pense
que ça rend un peu plus humble et
peut-être parfois un peu moins agressif
vis-à-vis de ses collègues je me croise
la commission des finances il intervient
ont ils fait des interventions
techniques
assez précises a été ministre
de l'économie connaître sujet après on
peut pas dire qu'ils mettent beaucoup de
lyrisme
beaucoup de chair beaucoup de passion
dans ses interventions de quelqu'un qui
a beaucoup d'humour
sérieux compétence fidélité alors avec
votre ont mûri on apprendre de
l'expérience mais est-ce qu'on change
vraiment trop d'état d'âme politique
quand on est un homme ou une femme tout
court non on change pas on est ce qu'on
est et puis après on essayer de
s'améliorer de gommer les points faibles
et puis de renforcer peut-être les
quelques les quelques qualités que
chacun d'entre nous il peut y en avoir
plein
parfois si le manque de confiance en soi
qu'on essaie de rééquilibrer les risques
oui non je suis pas lyrique parce que je
pense que le lyrisme parfois c'est juste
fait pour éviter de répondre aux
questions qu'on vous pose et dans le
monde politique aujourd'hui la vraie
question c'est de répondre aux questions
qu'on vous pose j'essaierai d'ailleurs
de répondre aux questions aux politiques
et ces femmes et j'essaie
boyer dis que j'ai dû m'en j'essaie de
enfin j'espère avoir de l'humour parce
que c'est aussi une forme de
distanciation c'est aussi avoir l'humour
sur soi même c'est très important et
justement on va commencer par la
question du lundi le système français
d'indemnisation du chômage et elle est
trop généreux
françois hollande a tenté de calmer le
jeu sur la réforme possible de
l'assurance chômage la négociation est
renvoyé à 2016 entre les mains des
partenaires sociaux comme une réponse
aux déclarations d' emmanuel macron et à
la petite phrase prononcée en coulisses
par manuel valls retour sur qui a dit
quoi avec elsa monde à gaven une journée
rythmée par les déclarations
intempestives sur l'assurance chômage
première à se manifester françois
hollande le chef de l'état a tenté de
calmer les esprits échauffés par les
récentes déclarations de son
gouvernement la négociation sur le sujet
viendra le moment venu pas immédiatement
comme une réponse à la sortie des
manuels macron qui marche dans les pas
de manuel valls dans les colonnes du
journal du dimanche il ya eu une réforme
elle est insuffisante on ne pourra pas
en rester là à la mi journée les
syndicats ont vivement réagi c'est ce
qu'ils aiment de plus c'est d'abord
qu'il n'ait pas fait référence au fait
que dans notre pays aujourd'hui
un chômeur sur deux ne touchent pas
d'indemnités ce qui me choque également
c'est que l'on met sur le devant de la
scène une idée selon laquelle les
chômeurs seraient des profiteurs alors
que ce sont les principales victimes de
la dégradation du marché de l'emploi
dans l'après midi le ministre de
l'économie est revenue sur son interview
sans rien regretter mais en voulant
dédramatiser j'ai bien indiqué que la
réforme de l'assurance chômage devraient
être regardé en temps voulu et donc il y
à une litanie des temps les partenaires
sociaux viennent de signer un accord
nous l'avons est tout à fait acceptée
plus sur la table et homologué en 2015
et 2016 évidemment des discussions
seraient ouvriront et je n'ai dit que la
vérité est que ce qui est sur la table
mais cela ne s'arrête pas là puisque le
ministre du travail a déclaré en marge
d'un déplacement
il n'y a pas lieu dans l'immédiat de re
négocier quoi que ce soit
l'exécutif n'est pas à une contradiction
près à se demander si tout cela ne
serait pas calculer à quelques jours de
l'examen du budget français par
bruxelles
alors justement parce que c'est une
réforme nécessaire ou est-ce que s'est
imposée sans le dire par la commission
européenne d'abord dans quoi que ce soit
et à quoi qu il ya beaucoup de il ya
beaucoup de couacs dans le gouvernement
sur sept sur sept semaines md couac
sérieux c'est à dire que sur
l'indemnisation du chômage au fond quand
mise l'économie parle ou le premier
ministre c'est pas juste pour donner des
idées ils sont pas dans un signe quand
ils sont dans un gouvernement photo d
ouais enfin ils disent on va le faire il
faut le faire et puis finalement
regardez-moi se dire qu'on prend pas
puis d'un autre côté vous avez marisol
touraine qui dit on touchera pas aux
l'universalité des allocations
familiales
après ils font oui mais je met en
parallèle tous et tous ces sujets
évidemment sur sur la sur
l'indemnisation du chômage mais bon
c'est un sujet très très difficiles
notamment quand on est dans un chômage
de masse c'est très compliqué parce que
vous avez le sentiment de stigmatiser
des chômeurs c'est évidemment pas la
volonté la vraie question c'est est-ce
que ou pas les systèmes de protection
sociale tels qu'ils sont construits
aujourd'hui et notamment le système
d'indemnisation du chômage est ce qu'ils
ne rendent pas impossible le retour sur
le marché du travail est-ce qu'ils
empêchent l'incitation à la reprise du
travail qu'est ce que oui il faut
changer il faut modifier ce système
d'indemnisation du chômage il faut
réduire il faut réduire la durée il faut
il faut que le pouvoir politique prenne
apprennent ça prenne ses responsabilités
je ne crois pas aux je ne crois pas que
les partenaires sociaux pour pour
laquelle j'ai beaucoup de respect je les
connais bien mais je ne crois pas que
les partenaires sociaux peuvent au fond
faire des réformes de structure des
réformes de fond car passer un palier
loyers supplémentaires dans la réforme
il faut changer transformer profondément
un certain nombre de choses je crois pas
que ce soit le rôle des partenaires
sociaux qui peuvent accompagner qui
peuvent gérer qu'ils peuvent
c'est bien sûr c'est le rôle du
politique parce qu'on est dans une
démocratie politique du gouvernement
évidemment donc du politique et la
légitimité politique c'est pas possible
autrement et si on fait une réforme de
l'indemnisation du chômage il n'est pas
suffisante il faut évidemment à côté
faire une réforme du marché du travail
et la formation professionnelle sa place
à côté voulait réduire la durée on
touche au montant si oui il faut toucher
au montant vous touchez malgré que des
trucs
très difficile à expliquer aux français
je le comprends très très bien et on
était
peut-être moi je les fais déjà sur les
retraites et je pense que j'avais 13 ans
passant sans fausse modestie n'ont pas
faim non il faut pas passer par la rue
mais il faut expliquer il faut beaucoup
expliquer il faut expliquer
qu'aujourd'hui 600 milliards de dépenses
sociales c'est juste plus possible pour
notre pays on peut pas les payer et on
les paye à crédit ça veut dire que les
générations futures vont payer et
qu'elle est la plus forte des brutalités
est-ce que c'est d'imposer des réformes
aujourd'hui pour que chacun soit
responsable de ça de sa propre main que
nos générations soit responsable d'elle
même ou est ce que c'est de mettre un
crédit est à la charge des générations
futures des réformes qu'on n'a pas osé
faire nous mêmes je pense que la réponse
est les tutsis la brutalité au moins le
gouvernement d'als les propos dia jamais
eu autant de fois le saumon réforme de
prononcer je sais pas ce gouvernement
comme le disait c'est pas un think tank
donc un gouvernement c'est d'abord un
lieu où on décide je remarque bah oui et
je remarque que laisse moi une minute je
remarque que il ya beaucoup de débats
internes au gouvernement il ya eu un
débat de gauche le ps de gauche avec
montebourg et hammonds exit mon beau et
bon maintenant il ya un débat de droite
de ps2 droite avec valse et macron on
libéralise le travail du dimanche on
change l'indemnisation du chômage etc on
verra et puis à hollande au milieu
président la république milieu qui
essayent de vaguement arbitrer en disant
d'ailleurs des choses assez différentes
de jour en jour et puis un électron
libre une électronique qui est madame
royal qui ne se situe ni d'un côté ni de
l'autre et qui propose fur et à mesure
de 6 d'humeur ça veut dire qu' il n'y a
pas de ligne il n'y a pas deux il n'y a
pas de cap on sait pas bien où on va et
on peut pas gérer le pays comme ça
surtout dans une crise comme celle que
nous traversons est justement renvoyé le
budget examiné à l'assemblée on voit ça
c'est mardi
le budget à l'époque du gouvernement en
france et sous l'oeil de bruxelles le
gouvernement se retrouve pris entre les
taux une partie de sa gauche évidemment
et les européens qui demandent toujours
plus à paris on voit ça avec elisa
bartholomé pas d'augmentation d'impôts
voilà le leitmotiv du budget 2015 au
contraire le gouvernement veut rendre du
pouvoir d'achat aux ménages les plus
modestes
la première tranche du barème de l'impôt
sur le revenu va être supprimé plus de 6
millions de ménages verront leur impôt
diminuer c'est le premier pilier de ce
budget qui en comporte deux autres une
relance de l'investissement dans le
bâtiment donc là aussi avec des efforts
significatifs et bien sûr une baisse des
dépenses publiques mais qui est une
baisse
qui calibre et de manière à faire en
sorte que la croissance puisse puisse
renaître dans le pays de 21 milliards
d'économies seront réalisées en 2015 et
malgré les doutes de la commission
européenne sur la loi de finances la
majorité n'entend pas en réaliser plus
pas question de freiner la maigre
reprise de la croissance avec une
politique de rigueur mais ces économies
ne sont pas suffisantes pour
l'opposition un budget qui repose la
fois sur des bases de croissance qui
sont fausses lui sont contestés par tout
le monde et puis un budget en trompe
l'oeil où il n'y a pas de baisse de
dépenses publiques principaux ministères
touchés par les baisses de dépenses la
défense les finances et le logement
comme les années précédentes trois
ministères restent sanctuary zay
l'éducation l'intérieur et la justice
alors eric woerth françois fillon que
vous soutenez a qualifié ce budget de ni
honnête ni responsable ce qui a
scandalisé la gauche est ce que vous
reprendriez ces termes oui enfin il est
il est pas sincère et puis il est
effectivement je trouve irresponsable
il n'est pas sincère parce que corps le
gouvernement annonce 50 milliards c'est
un chiffre totem 50 milliards
d'économies sur trois ans c'est pas des
vraies économies et tout le monde le
sait tout le monde maintenant est au
courant que c'est uniquement une
réduction de la tendance en augmentation
de l'ensemble des dépenses publiques les
dépenses publiques sur les trois ans
augmenté d'à peu près 100 5 milliards
d'euros nous dit le gouvernement et ils
font 50 milliards d'économies donc la
gauche d'authie comment vous trouvez
donc des fonds publics va augmenter à
dire faire des économies mais le
résultat c'est que la dépense publique
elle va augmenter d'une bonne
cinquantaine de milliards sur les trois
ans qui est ce budget il ne comprend pas
de réformes de fond il n'y a pas de
réforme de fond il ya des aménagements
il ya ici ou là certains nombre de
choses il n'y a pas de réforme de fond
et il est impossible il est impossible
de d'économiser réellement de l'argent
sans réforme de de fond et tout ça se
traduit parfois par une paupérisation de
l'administration était plus qu on
demande à l'administration de faire
toujours plus mais toujours sans jamais
la réforme et connaissant est chargé
mais la réforme est en réalité à un
moment donné elle commence à se
paupériser on le voit d'ailleurs et on
voit au ministère de la défense ce qui
est particulièrement grave car d'une
certaine façon la france est en guerre
elle est en guerre contre contre l'état
islamique contre elle étant et voilà et
au mali n'a pas les moyens d'aller faire
la guerre on doit le faire si notre
souveraineté mais en même temps je dois
dire que la situation on a dit on a des
moyens extraordinairement restera est
très compliqué je puisse pas qu'on
puisse je ne pense pas qu'on puisse
engager projeter vos
noms s'applique non si sanctuariser
c'est ce qu'on dit tout le temps mais
c'est pas vrai d'abord les recettes ne
sont pas sanctuariser vous avez des
recettes qui ne qui n'existe pas la
vente de l'immobilier militaire comme
leaf des fréquences tout ça n'existe pas
aujourd'hui pour revenir au budget vous
dit tiens il n'y a pas de réforme de
fond selon vous il ya quand même une
mesure emblématique la suppression de la
1ère tranche de l'impôt sur le revenu
une mesure de justice fiscale selon elle
c'est pas une réforme de fond monsieur
ayrault nous avait dit on va faire une
énorme réforme fiscale c'est vrai que
quelque chose change pas écouté on a
massacré les ménages pendant deux heures
et demie puis tout d'un coup on y voit
là haut le coeur fiscales donc c'est
vrai que des montagnes russes sans arrêt
ça donne un peu mal au coeur pour le
coeur fiscale mais j'ai le hockey et
puis on baise tout d'un coup d'une
manière assez rapide on supplie
non c'est sale c'est pas très
démagogique de la part de le dire je
pense que le on est en train de tuer à
petit feu l'impôt sur le revenu l'impôt
sur le revenu c'est le seul apport
réellement perceptible vous savez ce que
vous payez vous savez pas combien ont
payé de tva vous savez pas combien vous
payez au fond de charges sociales mais
voyez vous payez c'est le lien en
réalité entre le contribuable et la
nation c'est ce lien à très très
important c'est très important la
confiance
du citoyen dans son système garde sa
démission parce que c'est ce qui vous
permet quand même de pouvoir continuer à
emprunter sur des marchés extérieurs
parce qu'il sait après que vous serez
donc il faut faire attention à ça mais
l'impôt sur le revenu il va être de plus
en plus concentré et il est déjà très
concentré 1 % des contribuables payent
plus 30 % de l'impôt sur le revenu 20 %
des contribuables payent 80% l'instant
je dis que l'impôt sur revenu il faut en
conserver la progressivité aujourd'hui
il est très progressif il est très
concentré et il faut pas le sur
concentré parce qu'à ce moment-là tous
ceux qui sont en haut ils s'en vont et
tous ceux qui sont en bas perdre le lien
tout simplement dudu
du financement des services eu les
rivages et disait tout à l'heure qu'on
était aussi sous l'oeil de bruxelles
est-ce qu'il faut attendre et nous façon
très courte est-ce qu'il faut attendre
un peu de mansuétude de la part de
bruxelles moi je pense le gouvernement
se trompe dans son diagnostic alors on
me dit les économistes l'avaient fait
mille enfin le fmi qui change aussi
davies assez souvent fonctionné ce
budget c'est beau c'est leur raison de
dire que ça suffit
ils auraient raison de dire que ça de
l'avoir sanctionné ils auraient raison
de dire que la france ne respecte aucun
de ses engagements et quand vous jouer
collectif il faut bien à un moment donné
respecter ses engagements quand vous
êtes sur un terrain de foot et que vous
êtes 11 si vous jouez avec des règles
différentes mais ça marche pas donc il
faut qu'ils aient des règles et c'est
pour ça qu'on à l'euro et il faut
absolument qu'on respecte ses règles
même si la conjoncture est plus
difficile que prévu il faut quand même
respecter ces règles et on a un tel
niveau de dépenses publiques un tel
niveau de déficit ce budget c'est le
budget delà du renoncement c'est le
renoncement officiel de la france à
réduire ses déficits c'est ça que ça
veut dire ce budget cette trajectoire de
finances publiques et nous ne devrions
pas faire ça parce que on ne trouvera
pas la croissance en augmentant le
déficit de la france c'est exactement le
contraire maintenant on va parler un
petit peu de politiques et de votre
parti si vous voulez bien de retour est
plutôt difficile pour nicolas sarkozy
qui poursuit sa chute dans les sondages
l'ancien chef d'état a subi une forte
baisse dans le baromètre
ipsos le poids qui est paru ce week-end
est l inverse alain juppé lui poursuit
son envol droit cela avec samia paix
scheer c'est un peu sa revanche alain
juppé l'homme qu'on disait fini en 2004
fait aujourd'hui figure de favori pour
la primaire ump les derniers sondages
lui donnent 12 points d'avancé sur
nicolas sarkozy
une course qui se joue pour l'instant
moins sur les programmes que sur la
personnalité et c'est d'abord là que se
trouve la clé de son succès face à un
nicolas sarkozy jugé hyperactif bling
bling et surtout trop clivant rassembler
et surtout élargir au centre c'est
l'autre clé du succès juppé quand
nicolas sarkozy séduit davantage le
noyau dur de l'ump je n'ai pas à juger
au sein de l'ump qui sera privilégiée
par les uns ou par les autres mais en
tout cas ce qui est clair c'est qu'on a
un vrai partage d'idées et de valeurs
sur les questions écologiques et sur
notre vision d'avenir de la société si
la montée en puissance d'alain juppé
fait de l'ombre à nicolas sarkozy c'est
aussi l'autre candidat françois fillon
qu'elle pénalise avant qu'alain juppé
monte en puissance le duel annoncé
serait sarko et fillon maintenant qu'il
est cette montée en puissance le duel
annoncé sarkozy et juppé alors ces
choses là peuvent encore bouger mais la
vraie difficulté pour françois fillon à
mon avis c'est que françois fillon a
pris un positionnement très en pointe de
thatchérisme la française ce
positionnement est minoritaire à
l'intérieur même de la droite mais
françois fillon peut compter sur le
soutien d'une centaine de parlementaires
et nicolas sarkozy a toujours la
confiance des militants mieux que
personne alain juppé c'est que les
sondages peuvent s'inverser d'ici à 2016
alors alain juppé devant nicolas sarkozy
phénomène ponctuel aux tendances de fond
on en parle c'est le zouk de la semaine
jean daniel lévy nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau bonjour vous êtes directeur du
pôle politique opinion d'harris
interactive instituts de sondage alors
expliquez nous est ce que ce sera un
match à 200 françois fillon commande est
passée de nicolas sarkozy françois
fillon et nicolas sarkozy
il ya des histoires de d'imagés des
passations d'image de françois fillon
s'est notamment toujours
positionné sur une ligne de clivage
extrêmement claire par rapport au front
national est ce qu'on a pu voir dans les
enquêtes d'opinion c'est qu'à partir du
moment où il a indiqué notamment que
dans le cas des élections municipales il
pourrait être amené à voter pour le
moins sectaires d2 entre le front
national et un candidat socialiste il ya
une forme d'interrogations de la part
notamment des sympathies omp autour de
l'idée sommes nous face à un
positionnement keita positionnement de
fond de françois fillon vous passez un
plissement qui est un prix remontent à
petit et donc à une forme
d'interrogation profonde au départ
effectivement renforcée parce qu'elle
était indiqué tout à l'heure un
positionnement qui est un positionnement
qui apparaît comme étant très libérale
et on sait que en france le mot libéral
apparaît comme étant un gros mot avec
eric woerth évidemment aussi parlé de
françois fillon moi je sais ce que je
veux savoir c'est est ce qu'il ya
vraiment une envie d'alain juppé il ya
aujourd'hui elle envie d'avoir une
personne qui est une personne posée on a
envie d'avoir une personne d'une
personne qui apparaît comme étant
responsable et qui a une vision d'avenir
les ados ce contexte là ça apparaît
comme étant plus traduit à l'heure
actuelle dans ce moment que nous
connaissons est un moment alain juppé
parle un gp parce qu'alain juppé dans le
sentiment que du fait de son expérience
il arrive à pouvoir rassembler un peu
leste et française parce qu'il donne le
sentiment d'avoir un cap et le fait
d'être passé et par une étape de purges
entre guillemets à l'étranger et d'avoir
été ministre des affaires étrangères lui
confère en tout cas actuellement cette
forme de stage chez eric woerth vous
étiez de tous les meetings de nicolas
sarkozy ce que votre choix est fait pour
la pour la primaire a pour la primaire
non non pas pour la primaire pour la
présidentielle de l'ump oui je voterai
nicolas sarkozy et je l'aide à l'aide a
réformé l'ump sur la primaire il faut
laisser les choses ouverte je pense
absolument qu'ils voulaient je pense
qu'elle se jouera entre ces trois hommes
fillon
juppé sarkozy je remarque d'ailleurs que
vous parliez duels et on annonçait un
duel fillon sarkozy maintenant on
annonce un duel juppé sarkozy reste
toujours sarkozy ou moins mais je
voudrais juste redire que parmi ces
trois hommes ces trois personnalités
trois tempéraments vous le dit très bien
différent je ne sais pas dans quel état
sera la france en 2017 et ou non plus
aucun aux auditeurs on verra bien ce qui
compte c'est que la droite elle avance
avec des gens de qualité et talent et
puis je pense que le collectif qui doit
aider ces trois candidats et puis
d'autres s'il y en a a essayé de le
sortir la fin de faire en sorte que le
programme de réformes sur un programme
de réformes dures difficiles que ce
programme de réformes il soit aussi
assorti d'une vraie vision de l'avenir
de notre pays on a besoin d'une grande
énergie et on a aussi besoin d'une
grande tranquillité elle vit si on fait
une comparaison vous l'avez fait tout à
l'heure sur les 3 es ce que vous avez
l'impression que que la presse
finalement a déjà écrit le match une
façon de la presse attend un match
histoire elle est déjà écrit une finale
donc jamais écrite évidemment les
l'histoire n'est pas écrite je rejoins
entièrement ce qu'était à une autre
personne ne peut savoir où nous en
serons dans un an et demi il ya
aujourd'hui clairement l'idée d'une
campagne électorale de nicolas sarkozy
qui d'un point de vue d'opinion se passe
un peu moins bien qu est ce qui était
prévu mais malgré tout quand on regarde
froidement les sondages il reste encore
une des personnalités privilégié de la
part des français de la part de ces
matières droite et même des sympathies
sauf que le match face au moc et éric
vachon la phrase comme celle de cette
semaine de françois fillon si la
primaire n'est pas honnête je serai
candidat au premier tour quoi qu'il
arrive le match est serré et ça va être
costaud quand même françois fillon est
la raison il a raison de dire si jamais
si c'est pas honnête et si on veut la
primaire je serai candidat là
lorsqu'elle à la primaire ce sera le
premier tour de l'élection dissidente à
paris mais il a fixé comme une arme de
dissuasion c'est comme l'armé nucléaire
les fins connaisseurs
balladur j'espère pas parce qu'elle ce
moment là le danger du front national
est très important avec conseils sont en
colère et puis voilà je viens
d non il dit si une primaire solide si
une vraie primaire ce qui sera le cas
enfin je l'espère de gars c'est la seule
façon mais je n'en sais rien il faut
lutter
c'était assez simple je deviens si la
primeur et louper si la primaire elle
est mal organisé si la primaire elle est
dévoyé comme on a vu il ya deux ans
tours et c'est bien naturel il dire à
moi je dans ce cas là je participerai au
premier tour ça veut bien dire que si
c'est aussi une bonne primaires si une
primaire ouverte et si une primaire
organisée par une ump qui s'est
ressaisie qui s'est rassemblée avec un
socle idéologique commun entre les uns
et les hoba à ce moment là les ailes ce
qu'ils feront à la primaire
départageront et nous aurons un seul
candidat et c'est ça que je souhaite
merci jean daniel lévy d'avoir été avec
nous a parlé vous souvenez vous parliez
de quoi coûte peut-être de cafouillages
en a eu quand même cette semaine assez
important ce sont les les autoroutes
gratuites le week end voilà l'idée
lancée par ségolène royal la ministre de
l'écologie vous savez qu'elle ait mis
fin la semaine dernière à l'écotaxe la
ministre a eu beau le progrès recadré en
tout cas pour le premier et pour le
président de la république est bien la
ministre maintient sa parole est libre
on va regarder le reportage de mounir
soucis après l'abandon de l'écotaxe le
gouvernement cherche comment combler le
manque à gagner de 450 millions d'euros
plusieurs pistes sont à l'étude comme
l'augmentation de 2 centimes du litre de
gasoil et pour compenser cette
éventuelle hausse pour les ménages
ségolène royal a quelques idées ce que
je souhaite c'est que il ya une baisse
des tarifs d'autoroutes de 10% avec une
gratuité par exemple le week-end et tout
ça est à discuter des négociations
serrées déjà engagé avec les sociétés
d'autoroutes qui refuse de faire un
geste s abriter derrière le contrat de
concession signé en 2006 il leur assure
une compensation en cas de perte de
bénéfices dus à des décisions de l'état
la marge de manoeuvre est mince pour le
gouvernement manuel valls tiens donc à
rester prudent il faut traiter ces
questions avec beaucoup de sérénité la
ministre de l'écologie a envisagé un
certain nombre de solutions mais pour ce
qui concerne la gratuité les autoroutes
aujourd'hui c'est une question qui n'est
pas à l'ordre du jour merci manuel valls
balaie la proposition de ségolène royal
une manière de recadrer sa ministre mais
qui n'évacue pas le débat ce week-end le
ministre du budget a appelé à mettre la
pression sur les sociétés d'autoroutes
une idée relayée dans les couloirs de
l'assemblée nationale les photos
renationaliser les autoroutes parce que
la privatisation des autoroutes
tous les rapports leur montrer de la
cour des comptes de l'autorité la
concurrence à voler l'état français il
ya eu vol
malgré le rappel à l'ordre du premier
ministre ségolène royal n'en démord pas
elle continuera à proposer des idées
fortes dit elle de sa liberté de parole
pourtant la gratuité pour les autoroutes
les week-ends c'est quoi être bien sûr
populaire mais dans tous les sens du
terme elle s'appelle des idées fortes
les idées creuses c'est pas tout à fait
la même chose c'est quand même pas
normal qu'ils aient un ministre qui se
promène comme ça dans le gouvernement
dise un peu ce qui lui passe par la tête
ne regarde pas ses dossiers parce
qu'elle sait très bien que juridiquement
c'est pas possible ça demande un peu de
sérieux quoi seulement l'affection mais
pas faire jouer les choses ça demande du
sérieux on peut bousculer les choses on
peut ne pas accepter le politiquement
correct vous y allez bien évidemment il
faut les faire bouger enfin là elle fait
rien bouger du tout qu'est ce qu'elle a
fait bouger au fond elle a fait bouger
que ce sont les français qui paieront 4
centimes de plus de gazole le ddd dès le
mois de janvier elle c'est ça la réalité
des choses et des postures moi je
m'interroge à la fois sur la posture de
manuel valls et la fois sur celle de
ségolène royal qui veulent j'en sais
rien j'ai l'impression qu'ils veulent se
désolidariser un peu du bateau hollande
qui est en train de couler avec le
maître france malheureusement et au fond
manuel valls il veut pas couler avec le
bateau et les premiers estime ne pas
couler avec le bateau donc ils essayent
de faire des propositions qui vont
conserver son image de réformateur tout
en sachant qu'elles ne sont pas acceptés
par le président de la république c'est
un jeu ambigu et c'est pas jeu c'est un
jeu qui est très éloignée de l'intérêt
général du pays elle leur propose aussi
ségolène royal parce qu'on parle d'elle
de revoir éventuellement que l'état
revoie les conditions du contrat passé
avec eco move qu'est ce que vous en
pensez si n'importe quoi il ya un
contrat une concession à dépasser d'un
bond conditions on le veut dire il ya
voilà
content il se met très bien mais enfin
virage ou ne le problème n'est pas n'est
pas là il ya un contrat une concession
qui était passé dans un certain nombre
de conditions ça fait deux ans et demi
que les socialistes se pose ces
questions là deux ans et demi qu'il ne
le résolvent pas qu'il va respecter le
contrat la france de respecter ses
engagements si à l'entracte et s'il a
évidemment interdit les choses n'ont pas
été faites n'importe comment
contrairement à ce que dit madame royal
sur les plateaux de télé faudra juste
qu'elle le lise alors on va passer à
mercredi le ministre de l'économie on en
parle il veut libérer la france de ces
blocages
emmanuel macron à dévoiler la
philosophie générale de son futur projet
de loi sur l'activité bientôt débattu au
parlement il propose notamment d'étendre
les possibilités de travailler le
dimanche et de toucher aux professions
réglementées
explications d'elisa bertolo n'est
libéré investir et travailler c'est la
devise de la future loi activité
présentée par emmanuel macron ce
mercredi elle vise selon le ministre de
l'économie a lutté contre 3 maladie
française la défiance la complexité et
le corporatisme
l'objectif comme j'ai plusieurs fois eu
l'occasion de le dire ici de ce projet
de loi c'est véritablement de
déverrouiller notre économie de libérer
là où c'est possible
l'activité c'est à dire de simplifier
massivement les règles devenu obsolète
de préserver les règles utile là où
elles existent
l'exécutif veut modifier les règles
régissant le travail le dimanche les
commerces pourront ouvrir lorsqu'ils
sont situés dans les gares et dans les
zones touristiques à fort potentiel
économique
autre mesure la libéralisation du
transport par autocar des lignes
pourront être ouvertes partout sans
autorisation préalable dans le cas des
professions réglementées
le gouvernement veut simplifier les
conditions d'installation des
professions juridiques notaires avocats
huissiers dans le domaine de la santé
les dentistes seront invités à plus de
transparence sur le coup des prothèses
dentaires le regroupement des capitaux
des pharmacies sera favorisée et la
vente sur internet développé on peut
faire mieux plus simple vite et mieux
pour le territoire
en ouvrant le capital entre les
professionnels là aussi et en leur
permettant de mieux s'organiser sur
internet parce qu'aujourd'hui les
critères sont très rigides un pharmacien
pharmaciens je le dis bien doit pouvoir
vendre plus facilement des médicaments
sur internet parce que c'est aussi un
bon service bien il faut ouvrir ses
règles pour leur permettre là aussi de
moderniser la profession d'aller vers le
vert +2 digital plus de numérique et
d'être plus efficace ces annonces ne
sont que les premières pistes de la loi
activités le projet de loi définitif
sera présenté en décembre en conseil des
ministres avant une discussion au
parlement début 2015 eric woerth libéré
investir travailler voilà un langage
très libérale finalement cette future
loi mâcon ça aurait pu être une réforme
adoptée sous le sous le quinquennat de
nicolas sarkozy pas mal de choses ont
été faites elle est dans le droit fil
des lois de on essaie de débloquer ou
refuser de débloquer la société
française qui bloquait bien d'autres
l'ont dit il ya très longtemps donc oui
il faut tenter de débloquer la société
française moi je voudrais savoir où sont
les 6 milliards où sont les 6 milliards
moby par heure alors nommé monsieur
montebourg parce que c'est la loi de
monsieur montebourg transformé par
monsieur m monsieur montebourg à 10,6
milliards qu'on va récupérer sur les
professions qui bloquent le pays et ils
sont où ces 6 milliards il était
ministre à la république il et ses
milices de cheveux plus quoi arrêter
c'est utile
elle a été chiffrée par le tai chi vrai
par le ministre avant donc je voudrais
savoir où sont les 6 milliards
d'ailleurs je ne remarque que c'est toi
qui s'appelait avant loi sur pour la
croissance devient une loi pour
l'activité s'est pas tout à fait la même
chose sur les tendances et objectifs il
dans le fond on ne peut être que
favorable tout ce qui peut débloquer la
société française donc lorsque ce sont
des mauvais blocage il faut le faire
tout ce qui peut protéger la société
française quand son bonne protection il
faut continuer à le faire vous êtes un
set à quelque part que cette fois vous
pourriez la beauté je n'en sais rien on
verra ce qui est de la grande bleue
train sur le travail du dimanche n'est
pas difficulté avec ça j'ai toujours
considéré que ça valait bien sûr il faut
réglementer elle est faite ici si elles
sont réglementées si souvent qu'il ya
des raisons alors parfois il ya de
mauvaises raisons mais il ya aussi des
boeufs ici on prend si on prend les
notaires par exemple aline auteurs ces
engins ils sont pas très populaires
souvent les notaires les notaires c'est
une profession absolument indispensable
à la solidité juridique de notre pays le
droit de propriété ne s'explique parce
qu'il ya un corps notariale qui est
extrêmement réglementée et donc les
règlements certes à des choses ne faut
pas déréglementé comme ça en rentrant du
doigt telle ou telle profession ces
professions doivent évoluer ils doivent
évoluer elles doivent bien sûr peu le
ministre parle d'internet tout ça tout
ça doit évoluer mais en même temps il
faut pas oublier l'essentiel parfois ça
a été réglementée parce qu'il y avait
une raison distribuer du médicament
s'est pas distribué des petits pains en
même temps signé des compromis de vente
c'est pas la chose dans d'autres pays il
n'y a pas ce type de sécurité et j'aime
autant vous dire que c'est autre chose
il ya aussi la fin je pense que c'est
peut-être la loire de la dernière chance
de son quinquennat moi je pense que
françois hollande n'a plus les tout neuf
et du tout aimé disait françois fillon
le france françois hollande n'a plus du
tout les moyens de nos jour d'hui de
réformer le pays comme il devra l'être
donc on lance des ballons d'essais ont
créé des débats à l'intérieur du
gouvernement ferait à sa place vous
pensez que la france est encore capable
de se réformer oui bien sûr qu'est ce
que vous mais évidemment piste
prioritaire réformer le marché du
travail celle enfin c'est même pas
réformer le marché du travail s'est créé
un marché du travail il n'y a pas de
marché du travail vous avez une offre
dans une offre vous voulez de
retravailler vous allez où mais chez
pôle emploi qui vous propose rien et
vous avez un décalage total entre votre
formation et ce qui est demandé par
l'entreprise d'à côté je parle même pas
des abus je parle de la réalité de ceux
qui cherchent un travail c'est
l'écrasante majorité de ceux qui de ceux
des chômeurs il n'y a pas de marché du
travail et pas de marché du travail
parce que tout est verrouillé toutes et
rigidifier créer un vrai système de
formation professionnelle
on met beaucoup d'argent et pourtant les
salariés français ne sont pas adaptés à
l'emploi qu'ils vont trouver investir
dans l'innovation la seule façon de
protéger notre industrie c'est la
développer dans
novation les frontières technologiques
qu'on doit briser c'est plus d'essayer
de copier ce qui est fait dans d'autres
pays à bas coûts toujours mercredi on va
aller cette fois à l'assemblée nationale
l'an passé voir thomas thévenoud thomas
thévenoud vous savez c'est l'éphémère
ministre du commerce extérieur qui avait
dû démissionner pour délicatesse avec le
fisc et bien il est apparu en commission
du développement durable c'est à la
surprise générale de ses collègues
thomas thévenoud les mauvaises langues
disent que ce retour et bié à une sorte
de règlement de l'assemblée nationale
qui stipule que vous devez être présent
au moins deux fois ont pas perdre vos
indemnités ou qu'est ce que vous en
pensez de ce retour rien enfin ce
programme est parti socialiste mais
aussi de notre problème aussi remarquer
rien enfin ça ne pas payer ses impôts
c'est voilà tout à fait
orthogonale comme on dira à bercy style
totalement contradictoire avec la
position de députés c'est-à-dire de la
fois de les voter et tout a été dit là
tu as précédent âme et conscience de
monsieur thévenot jeu le groupe
socialiste de la tude ailleurs à la
bonne me semble-t-il la bonne
interprétation j'ai pas de problème avec
ça mais il n'y a pas aujourd'hui dans
les textes et la possibilité de le faire
une sorte de gravité richmond c'est à
dire de dire voilà
pour certains cas certainement lorsqu'on
certains cas certainement et jeu c'est
comme ça c'est un peu c'est un peu
difficile et ça crée évidemment je
comprend une très très grande colère
chez nos chez nos concitoyens a la
phobie administrative c'est vrai que
c'est pas vraiment passé à autre chose
qui suscite beaucoup de colère maman
devant choc au budget de la sécu proposé
par le groupe socialiste à l'assemblée
avec le soutien du gouvernement il vise
les allocations familiales
les allocations familiales serait
modulée en fonction du revenu divisé par
deux à partir de 6000 euros de revenus
pour un couple par 4 à partir de 8000
euros nets imposables annonce a été
faite par la ministre de la santé
écoutez les explications du chef des
députés socialistes à l'assemblée moi je
travaille avec le gouvernement ensuite
le gouvernement se concerter avec le
président de la république mais j'ai
fait valoir les arguments du groupe
majoritaire à l'assemblée nationale ces
arguments c'était de dire que le poids
les allocations familiales n'est pas le
même pour une famille très modeste qui
gagne 1000 1200 euros par mois que pour
une famille qui a plus de dix mille
euros et qu'il fallait donc tenir compte
de cela qu'il fallait conserver
l'universalité et c'est pour ça que nous
proposons que toutes les familles
puissent avoir des allocations
familiales mais l'universalité ça n'est
pas l'uniformité qu'il y avait jusqu'à
maintenant beaucoup de questions mais en
même temps à chaque fois qu'un
gouvernement a voulu s'attaquer à à tous
deux touchés aux allocations familiales
de jos forme de l'enad jospin à jean
marc ayrault en passant par la jupe et
ils ont renoncé ce qui va se passer
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas il faut
demander ça au gouvernement mais le
gouvernement déjà il a changé d'avis la
semaine dernière ils n'étaient pas
favorables parce que vous citez jeudi
c'est ça donc le jeudi d'avant ceni
n'est pas favori oui c'est une faute
dans ce pays est une faute france je
pense que les halles auxquels notre
politique familiale elle et
elle varie selon les ressources à
hauteur d'à peu près 50% 50% des
dépenses sur les allocations sur la
politique familiale dans son ensemble
avec beaucoup de dispositifs une grande
partie de ces dispositifs là par exemple
la page ce qui concerne les frais de
garde d'enfants tout ça est en fonction
des revenus et c'est très bien et une
grande partie de nos politiques sociales
doivent être en fonction des revenus
simplement il ya un moment donné faut
arrêter ça parce que c'est pas le sujet
le sujet des allocations familiales si
au fond d'essayer de montrer avec la
nation elle prend en compte l'enfant
soit quel que soit au fond là le revenu
des personnes et quand monsieur le
roadie dix mille euros c'est beaucoup
par rapport aux personnes qui gagnent
ensuite évidemment j'ai bien conscience
de tout cela sauf que et commence à 6
mille 6000 ces deux fois trois mille
pour un couple qui travaille ça arrive
quand je crois pas qu'ils veulent eux
sous bâche en ciel non non non mais je
crois pas qu'ils roulent sur l'or ce
couple il a pas de yacht je ne suis pas
certain que il était en train de vendre
et d'acheter un château c'est juste la
politique était juste un couple de
français qui a des revenus importants
mais mais qui en même temps fonde une
famille est reconnu par la société comme
fondant une famille et donc pour chaque
enfant il est un peu on lui donne un peu
de d'allocations familiales pour essayer
de réduire les charges liées à la
famille flick assez branché c'est
branché avec le quotient familial parce
que le quotient familial
le quotient familial hui il égalise au
fond les un pouvoir d'achat entre des
ménages qui ont qui ont des enfants et
des ménages qui n'en n'ont pas s'est
construit tout cela s'est construit oui
se construit essais bien construits et
cette politique familiale elle a montré
qu'elle était efficace le quotient
familial
aujourd'hui on touche aux allocations
pas peut-être pas de de la loi sur la
famille et notamment le mariage pour
tous est-ce que vous avez l'impression
que françois hollande est le président
qui a osé toucher à la famille oui je
pense que je ne pense pas que ce soit
volontaire je ne dis pas lille
absolument taper sur les familles je
pense que c'est pas comme ça j'espère
que ce n'est pas vrai mais dans les
politiques que le gouvernement mène je
remarque que c'est systématiquement les
familles qui trinquent c'était vrai pour
le quotient familial c'est vrai pour les
allocations familiales maintenant c'est
vrai d'ailleurs pour le complément pour
le congé parental en trois ans discuter
c'est vrai c'est vrai que le congé
parental n'est pas ce que c'est facile
parce que je pense que c est facile
c'est facile je vends ma famille c'est
plus facile de faire cela puisqu'ils
disent pas d'une voyez on ne touche pas
l'universalité puisque on continuera à
verser à tout le monde c'est un peu
paradoxal d'ailleurs ça veut dire que
quand vous gagnez 6000 euros c'est
vraiment assez injuste de vous donner
129 euros si vous avez deux ans de
branguily par contre vous donner la
moitié de 129 euros 65 euros ça je serai
ce sera juste ça c'est sûr
donner de l'argent vous en donner de
moins en moins donc ça sert de moins en
moins à quelque chose donc ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'au fur et à mesure
du temps vous allez en ayant mis le
doigt dans cet engrenage vous allez
supprimer les allocations familiales
pour beaucoup de gens et si toute notre
société est indexé sur les revenus bas à
un moment donné évidemment vous paierez
votre baguette de pain parce que c'est
un élément très important vous paierez
votre baguette de pain fonctions c'est
un impôt déguisé pour vous
bien sûr c'est un impôt déguisé c'est
une wii bien sûr mais c'est surtout et
une faute vous dites c'est une aussi les
fautes parce que on a quand même
construit un pacte républicain ça veut
pas dire que rien ne doit changer c'est
à dire que tout est tabou dans le
domaine de la retraite c'est par exemple
le régime par répartition on a essayé de
transformer changer l'âge tout ça c'est
c'est possible mais toucher aux régimes
par répartition transformé par exemple
un régime par capitalisation
c'est quand même pas tout à fait la même
chose si le contenu du pacte républicain
il ya deux trois choses qui sont contenu
du pacte républicain il faut revoir
notre système de protection sociale
aujourd'hui on dépense beaucoup trop
d'argent 600 milliards d'euros et ça
c'est évidemment impossible il faut pas
tuer ceux qui encore ceux qui encore
normalement doit faire consensus entre
tous les français on va s'intéresser
cette fois un livre dans le plus de
l'hebdo c'est le livre des rings et
gauche parce que vous l'avez lu ça
s'appelle le suicide français et bat des
records dans l'édition
et c'est vrai comment expliquer le
succès de ce livre d'eric zemmour il
caracole en tête dans les ventes
envolées sur la théorie du genre sur les
dangers de l'immigration ou encore sur
la réhabilitation de de péta qu'est ce
qui explique ce succès si mouvoir baril
s'est interrogé regardez ce reportage on
en discute juste après
le suicide français le dernier livre du
polémiste eric zemmour blais se vend par
milliers chaque jour 5 127 pages dans
lesquelles l'auteur revient sur 40
années qui selon lui ont défait la
france une obsession du déclin qui fait
vendre rien de nouveau pour son confrère
de rtl alain duhamel auteur d'une vision
bien différente de la france une
histoire personnelle de la vème
république et il ya eu en france 15
régimes en un peu plus de deux siècles
et à la fin de chaque régime avant le
régime suivant il y avait toujours
l'obsession du déclin généreux
l'obsession du déclin serré durand c'est
vraiment une manie française j'allais
dire que même l'obsession du déclin
c'est une passion française que je ne
partage absolument pas la peur du grand
remplacement marque aussi la pensée
d'eric zemmour les chiffres soulignent
forte aujourd'hui qu'elle ne l'était y
ait une ou deux générations parce que le
la distance idéologique entre les partis
de gouvernement s'est beaucoup réduite
parce que comme l'individualisme
l'emportent le poids classique des
appareils partisans à beaucoup des crues
alors il ya des phénomènes d'extrémisme
bien sûr mais en dehors des extrêmes il
ya beaucoup moins
d'incompatibilité non seulement entre
les dirigeants mais entre les français
eux mêmes de la mort du général de
gaulle en passant par la série hélène et
les garçons la chronologie de ce suicide
français est toute personnelle une chose
est sûre après la télévision et la radio
la technique polémique d'eric zemmour
fonctionne aussi sur papier technique
polémique mais qu'est-ce que cela dit de
la france d'aujourd'hui finalement il a
du talent zemmour après on aime ou on
n'aime pas mais il a dû il ya du talent
ça veut dire que la france se cherche
qu'on est dans une crise de la dette
vraiment d'identité ou de la note crise
économique et sociale qu'on sait plus ce
qu'on doit dire au monde on avait avant
une politique universelle déclaration
des droits de l'homme et bien d'autres
choses comme ça aujourd'hui on a même du
mal à se parler à nous mêmes donc si on
a une part la question de jean n'est pas
rentré dans le 21ème sur l'a8 la frotte
la france n'est pas rentrée chez elle
alors aussi oui elle a peur évidemment
les français sont en colère enfin tout
ça ce diagnostic est fait la vraie
question c'est comment on réagit et tout
cela comment on rentre quand on retrouve
les clés pour ouvrir la serrure et
pousser la porte du 21e siècle et la
france le peux je suis pas déclinistes
moi je suis optimiste je suis optimiste
si on sait se réformer si au fond la
classe politique parce que c'est de ça
dont on parle puisque dont on est en
démocratie est capable d'entraîner le
pays dans un mouvement à la fois de
réforme et qui veut dire quelque chose
qui veut dire quelquefois effectifs des
forces de la parole politique oui mais
il y en a toujours eu duhamel a raison
il y en a toujours eu la troisième
nicklas 4e challenge
repas je crois pas il ya des hauts et
des bas dans ce domaine là simplement on
doit pas s'en contenter il faut
transformer aussi notre démocratie ont
regardé le parti ce n'est pas en rester
là il faut l'adapter à son temps je suis
très optimiste pour le pays si ce serait
formé qu'ils utilisent pour finir c'est
très bien de la fin beaucoup eric maire
de vars était l'invité de par le web
docs et tiens on se retrouve là son
prochain la semaine prochaine avec
plaisir merci à tous de votre fidélité
rester avec nous sur lcp public sénat
les programmes